how's it going everyone it's Warren and
we have some brand-new Avengers in-game
toilets specifically about Ironman and a
brand new weapon as I've mentioned in a
few videos in the past the closer we get
to endgame coming out the more marketing
is going to kick in and the more leaks
we're going to get as well and as I
mentioned today is about Ironman with a
new weapon but before we get into that
just a reminder about my IMAX ticket
giveaway if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain alright so we have an Iron Man
toy League and as you can see this
figure is wearing what everybody is
calling his advanced tech suit and as
you can also see this Iron Man figure
comes with a huge weapon and if you look
on the back of the box you can also see
Iron Man wielding this weapon now you've
heard me talk about it many times in the
past but this looks like a proton cannon
now it doesn't look exactly like the one
that he has in Marvel vs. Capcom but it
is a very huge weapon and we've also
gotten some other leaks with war machine
wielding a massive cannon like weapon as
well so we're getting more evidence that
the proton cannon or some sort of
variation of it could end up in Avengers
endgame I say some sort of variation
because the Russo brothers aren't too
fond of just taking something from the
comics or a video game and just putting
it in the movie as is but they have
stated that they do draw inspiration
from the comics and the animated series
and other sources but they don't just
take it for what it is they add their
own little tweak to it and the one that
we saw in the war machine leaked does
look a little more true to the one that
we've seen in Marvel vs. Capcom but this
one for Ironman looks a little bit
different it looks like it's actually
firing a missile I've heard some people
say that it looks like a harpoon gun
perhaps targeting the Infinity Gauntlet
for the next time he goes against Thanos
to try and take it from him that does
seem a little too easy however Ironman
probably knows that that won't work
going against the mad Titan so this is
probably a weapon designed for a very
specific purpose based on how it looks
let's also remember what the Russo
brothers have said recently about toy
leaks they said that most the time the
toy leaks aren't 99% accurate they
didn't say they weren't real they said
they're not
accurate so this weapon could actually
be a lot bigger but the one thing that
this does show us is that Ironman is
going to be preparing for another fight
with feyo's by upgrading his armor and
his weapons and of course he is going to
be the one to design these advanced tech
suits as well probably with the help of
banner and possibly Scott Lang but we
know he's going to be the one to design
them and they're most likely nanotech so
we know that Ironman is going to get
some sort of weapon upgrade in Avengers
in game and these toy leaks are just
further evidence of that but let me know
what you think about this weapon in this
toilet let me know what you think it is
do you think it's some variation of the
proton cannon do you think it's a weapon
that fires missiles or do you think it's
some type of harpoon gun let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and again don't forget to subscribe
comment down below and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers endgame in all things Marvel as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]